One person
has died, two injured in Kiev,
in Ukraine this morning
after Russia launched
more than 30 missiles at the Cap
That is an air raid alert.
It remains in place over the cit
Moscow's latest attack has force
many residents to seek shelter
in the underground metro system.
Just look at that.
I remember those images
from the beginning of the war.
The city's
military spokesperson
said around 20 of those missiles
have been intercepted and destro
And these attacks come less than
after the United States
and Germany announced
they will send
those battle tanks to Ukraine, a
potentially to Putin that the al
may not be concerned
about provoking Russia.
The decision you saw today
by both Germany
and the United States was
was several weeks in the making
through many,
many discussions with the German
and with their allies in
allies and partners.
And it's about coordination.
It's about the
the unity here
and the resolve that
that we all have together
to help support Ukraine.
The Russian embassy in
Berlin
said this quote
is extremely dangerous decision.
It takes the conflict
to a new level of confrontation
that contradicts
the statements of German politic
about their unwillingness to hav
be drawn into it.
Fareed Zakaria, host of Fareed Z
GPS on CNN,
as with me, it's great to have y
Thank you so much.
So what do you think?
Big picture here.
Yes. It's a dramatic shift for G
But in terms of what it tells us
whether the West
really fears Putin at all anymor
Well,
I think
this is one of those cases
where the official line
actually is accurate,
that it really is
about the unity
and resolve of the Western power
It really is extraordinary,
if you think about it,
if you compare this war with som
like Iraq
on which half of Europe
was in violent opposition
to the United States,
a strategy here
you have
basically the entire western wor
plus a lot of non-Western countr
that have banded together
and they're ratcheting up
as the Russians reach up
because because
Putin has fundamentally decided
he can't beat the Ukrainian army
So he's going to try to defeat
the Ukrainian nation.
Those air raid sirens, you were
This is indiscriminate
bombing into a civilian part
a parts of the city, Kiev.
It's not you know,
I was there in September.
It's not a military city.
It doesn't
have huge military bases
he is just killing civilians.
And so in order to do something
what is what appears to be a som
congealed stalemate, on the fron
the western countries
are trying to ask themselves,
how can they move forward?
I think it's a really remarkable
display of the fact that you hav
with all the problems
created by Putin's invasion
or oil
crisis, energy crisis,
that the West is united.
You just interviewed
Vladimir Zelensky in Davos.
And I thought it was interesting
that he just told Sky News
in a new interview
that he is not interested, that
the quote in meeting with Putin.
And then he went on to say,
Putin is a
nobody sort of reflects
the sentiment you got from him a
Yeah.
And I think he in
some ways is reflecting the sent
in Ukraine.
I've noticed a very interesting
change with Zelensky
over the last year or two
at the start of the war,
when I would ask him about
whether or not
there was room for negotiation,
his answer was always yes.
His answer was, look,
there's a way around this.
There are formulas we can come u
We can describe the areas
that Russia occupies, has frozen
We will never accept that legiti
but we move on
And then came the brutality
of the Russian offensive,
the attacks on civilians,
the war crimes, the butcher, all
And I think it has turned the co
It has turned Ukraine.
One thing it's done
is this really created
a sense
of Ukrainian nationalism
far stronger than anything I'd s
But it's also created
an absolute determination
that they are not going to surre
They are going to see this
through to the end.
It is just so fascinating
isn't it,
to see the evolution of his lead
that so many question
when he got elected. Right.
And look what he has become.
Not the guy was a
was a call making producer.
And and it turned out that, you
we never know this about leaders
that when confronted with the cr
he had the one thing that perhap
you need above all else in a gre
which is which is courage. Coura
If he had not had the courage
that first day to say,
I don't need a ride, I need ammo
If he had run,
the whole history of this war
would be completely different.
I loved your op ed this weekend.
Sort of your takeaway from the W
Economic Forum in Davos
as it pertains to sort of
what will lead the world.
And it's not just the United Sta
You say
there are encouraging signs
that we are actually witnessing
is a new kind of order
built on unity,
of cooperation of the world free
And that just got accelerated,
did it not, with the US and Germ
coming together in this move thi
I'm so glad you
noticed that,
because what is this,
this latest tank business show u
The Germans were very concerned
about not wanting to be out in f
on this kind of thing.
And by the way,
we should all be very grateful
that the Germans are concerned
about not seeming too militarist
even though they have observe hi
that they are very conscious
of insensitive to.
So they said to the Americans, I
if you want us to do
this,
you've got to be in lockstep wit
And so the Americans
really largely simply to accede
to that German request,
agreed to send the Abrams tanks.
So it's a case of genuine cooper
Democratic leadership.
This is not Iraq.
This is not the United States sa
it's my way or the highway.
You know, people are being force
It's really consensus building,
which is what we have to hope
is going to happen.
In the future
because the US
ain't going to bear
the burden alone anymore.
And it does seem like this.
There's a kind of new
Democratic leadership
coming about I'm happy
to read about your optimism
after being with all of those le
Fred, thank you very much.
Of course, we'll be watching,
as we always do on Sunday. Thank